the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so so far we've seen things about
vectors equations of planes motions in
space and so on basically we've done
geometry in space but calculus really is
about studying functions so now we are
going to actually move on to studying
functions of several variables so this
new unit that what we'll do over the
next three weeks or so will be about
functions of several variables and their
derivatives okay so first of all we
should try to figure out how we are
going to think about functions so
remember if you have a function of one
variable that means you know you have
the quantity that depends on one
parameter
the F depends on a variable X and for
example you know the function that you
all know is f of X equals sine X and the
way we would represent that is using
maybe by plotting the graph of a
function so the graph of a function we
plot y equals f of X and the case of a
sine function that looks like this okay
so now let's say that we had actually a
function of two variables so that means
that the value of F depends actually on
two different parameters say the
variables are x and y or we could have
any names you want okay so given values
of the two parameters x and y the
function will gather will give us a
number that we'll call f of XY that
depends on x and y according to some
formula okay not very surprising so far
so
for example you know I can give you the
function f of X y equals x square plus y
squared and of course as with functions
of one variable we don't need things to
be defined everywhere sometimes there's
a domain of definition so this one is
defined all the time but if I tell you
say f of X y equals square root of Y
well this is only defined if Y is
non-negative if I tell you f of X y
equals 1 over X plus y well that's only
defined if X plus y is not 0 and so on
now so these are you know mathematical
examples given by explicit formulas and
of course there's physical examples or
examples coming from real life for
example you can look at you know the
temperature at a certain point on the
surface of the earth so you use maybe
longitude latitude that's x and y and
when you have f of XY equals the
temperature at that point
now in fact because temperature depends
also maybe on how high up you are it
depends on elevation so it's actually a
function of maybe X Y Z and it also
depends on time so in fact maybe it's a
function of T time XYZ coordinates in
space so you see that well world
functions can depend on a lot of
variables so our goal will be to
understand how to deal with that
okay so now you'll see very soon but
actually it's already quickly enough to
picture a function of two variables so
we are going to focus on the case of
functions of two variables and then
we'll see that if we have more than two
variables then it's harder to plot the
function we cannot know what the graph
looks like anymore but the tools are the
same the notion of partial derivatives
gradient vector and so on all the tools
that we will develop work exactly the
same way no matter how many variables
you have so and say for simplicity we'll
focus mostly on two or sometimes three
variables but it works the same in any
number of variables okay so the first
question is how do we visualize a
function of two variables so the first
thing we can do is try to hold the graph
of F so maybe I should say F which is a
function of two variables so the first
answer will be we can try to look at its
graph and the idea is the same as with
one variable namely we look at all the
possible values of the parameters x and
y and for each of them we plot a point
whose height is the value of a function
at these parameters so we'll plot let's
say Z equals f of X Y and now that we'll
be connecting a surface in space okay so
for each value
of X&Y yeah we have XY in the XY plane
then we'll plot the point in space at
position x y and z equals f of XY and if
we take all of these points together
they will give us some surface that sits
in space yes
Oh a function of two variables shorthand
well let's see how to visualize a
function of two variables if you want
okay so how do we do that concretely say
that I give you a formula for F how do
we try to represent it so let's do our
first example let's say that I give you
the function f of XY equals negative Y
okay so it looks a little bit silly
because it doesn't depend on X but
that's not a problem it's still a valid
function of x and y just happens to be
constant with respect to X so to draw a
graph we look at the surface in space
defined by Z equals minus y what kind of
surface is that it's a plane okay and if
we want to draw it the equals minus y
will look well that's the y-axis at
x-axis that's the z-axis if I look at
what happens in the Y Z plane in the
plane of a blackboard it will just look
like a line that goes downward with
slope one okay so it will do this and
what happens if I change X well if I
change X nothing happens because X
doesn't appear in this equation so in
fact if instead of setting X equal to
zero I set X equal to one and in front
of a blackboard or minus one and Verbeck
well it still looks exactly the same so
I have the
is I have this plane it actually
contains the x-axis and slopes downwards
with slope 1 it's kind of hard to do now
you see immediately what the big problem
with graphs will be but these pictures
are hard to read but so that's our first
time ok any questions so far ok so let's
say that we have a slightly more
complicated function how do we see it so
let's do another example let's say I
give you f of X y equals 1 minus x
squared minus y squared so we should try
to picture what the surface Z equals 1
minus X square minus y square looks like
so how do we do that
well maybe you're actually you know very
fast and you've already figured out what
it looks like but if not then we need to
work you know piece by piece
so maybe it will help if we understand
first what it does in the plane of a
blackboard ok so if we look at it in the
Y Z plane that means we set X equal to 0
and then Z becomes 1 minus y squared
what is that it's a parabola pointing
downward and starting at 1 okay so we
should draw maybe this downward parabola
start at 1 and it cuts the y axis at 1
okay when y is 1 that gives us 0 what do
we see let's you know so we might have
an idea of what it might look like or
maybe not
let's get more slices let's see what it
does in the
xz-plane this other vertical plane
that's coming to others so in the XZ
plane is we set y equal to zero and we
get Z equals one minus x squared it's
again a parabola coming downward
okay so I'm going to try to draw a
parabola that goes downward but now to
the front and to the back so we are
starting to have a slightly better idea
but we still don't know whether the
cross section of this thing might be you
know round square something else so if
we want more confirmation we might want
to also figure out maybe where does this
surface intersect the XY plane so we hit
the XY plane when z equals zero that
means 1 minus x square minus y squared
should be zero that becomes x squared
plus y squared equals 1 that is a circle
of radius one that's the unit circle so
that means that here we actually have
the unit circle and now you should
imagine that you have this thing that
when you slice it by a vertical plane
looks like a downward parabola and it's
actually a surface of revolution you can
rotate it around the z axis okay
now if you stay long enough at that
equation you'll actually see that yes
actually a posterior a we know that it
had to be like that but see so these are
useful ways of trying to guess what the
graph looks like of course the other way
is to just ask your computer to do it
and then you know you'll get that kind
of formula
okay well we can leave it on if you want
but no because I collected a different
function that I will show you later so
it goes this way I mean if you want one
- Minnie it's really going down what yes
I agree that the sheet is upside down
that's because I plotted something else
okay
so in fact well let me yeah so what I
plugged in my computer was actually X
square plus y squared that looks like
that see it's the same with a parabola
going upwards if you want to see more
examples and have various examples to
show well here's the graph of a function
y squared minus x squared C so that one
is kind of interesting it looks like a
saddle if you look at it in the Y Z
plane then it's a parabola going up Z
equals y squared and that's what we see
to the left and to the height but if you
put it in the XZ plane when it's a power
valuing downwards Z equals minus x
squared so we have a parabola going
downwards in one direction upward in the
other one and together they form this
surface and of course you can plots you
know much more complicated functions so
this one I well if you can evade very
small things and you can see the formula
but it doesn't matter just to show you
that you know you can put the formula
into a computer and it will show you a
picture okay
so that's pretty good better I mean you
can see that it can get a bit cluttered
because maybe that's features that are
hidden behind or maybe we have trouble
seeing if we don't have a computer you
know that looks very readable but this
is kind of hard to visualize sometimes
so there's another way to plot functions
of two variables and let's call the
contour plot so the contour plot is a
very elegant elegant solution to the
problem that it's difficult to draw
spaced pictures on a sheet of paper or
on a blackboard so instead let's try to
represent a function of two variables by
just a map you know the same way that
when you walk around you have actually
geographical maps that fit on a piece of
paper that tell you about what the real
world looks like so what the contour
plot looks like is something like this
so it's an XY plot and the next you have
a bunch of curves and what the curves
represent are the elevations on the
graph so for example this curve might
correspond to all the points where F of
XY equals 1 and that curve might be all
the points where F equals 2 and N equals
3 and so on okay so when you see this
kind of plot you're supposed to think
that the graph of a function is you know
somewhere sits in space above that it's
like a map telling you how high things
are and you know what you would want to
do with the function really is be able
to tell quickly what's the value at a
given point well let's say that I want
to look at that point I know that F is
somewhere between 1 and 2 you know
actually it's much faster to read than
the graph and because I might have to
look carefully and then measure things
and so on here I can just weighed the
value of F by comparing with the nearby
lines
okay so let me try to make that more
precise so this shows all the points so
where f of X y equals some fixed values
some fixed constant and this constant
typically are chosen at regular
intervals for example here I chose in
one two three and they could continue
with zero minus one and so on so one way
to think about it how does this relate
to the graph well that's the same thing
as cutting the difference a we slice the
graph by horizontal planes so horizontal
planes have equations of the form Z
equals some constant Z equals 0 Z equals
1 Z equals 2 and so on
so maybe the graph of my function will
be some sort of blow out there and if I
slice it by the plane Z equals 1 then I
will get the level curve which is the
points where type of XY equals 1 and so
that's called a level curve of F ok and
so we repeat the process with DS equals
two and we get another level curve and
so on and
that when we squeeze them all on the map
and that's how we get the contour plot
okay so each of these lines you know
imagine that this is like some mountain
of something that you're hiking on each
of these lines tells you how you could
move to stay at a constant height you
know if you want to get to the other
side of a mountain but without ever
going up or down
you just walk along that path and it
will get you there without effort so in
fact if you have been talking about
hiking on mountains well that's exactly
what a topographical map is about so I
need to zoom a bit so at a topographic
map this one is from the US Geological
Survey shows you basically all the level
curves of the altitude function on you
know a piece of land so you know that if
you walk along these curves you will
stay at the same height and you know
that if you walk towards all these don't
have numbers let me find a place with
numbers here there's a 500 in in the
middle so you know that if you walk on
the line that says 500 you stay always
at 500 meters in elevation
if you walk towards the mountain but I
think is below it then you will go up
and so on so you can see for example
here there's a peak and while here is a
valley with actually the river in it and
the altitudes go down and then back up
again on the other side so that's an
example of a contour plot of a function
of course we don't have a formula for
that function but we have a contour plot
and that's what we need actually to
understand what's going on there okay
any questions nope okay so another
example of contour plots well you've
probably seen various versions of these
you know temperature maps so that's
supposed to be how warm it is right now
so you know this one is color-coded
instead of having curves it has all of
these colors but the effect is the same
if you look at the separations between
consecutive colors these are the level
curves of a function that tells you the
temperature at a given point okay so
these are examples of contour plots in
real life okay
no questions nope okay so basically one
of the goals that one should try to
achieve at this point is you know
becoming familiar with the plot the
contour plot so if either contour plot
the graph and how to view and deal with
functions okay so
let's do an example well let's do a
couple of examples so let's start with F
of XY equals minus y and I'm going to
take the same two examples as there to
start with so that we you know we see a
very correlation between the graph and
the contour plot so let's try to plot it
so where's the level curve F equals zero
for this one well F is zero when y is
zero so that's the x-axis so that's the
level zero whereas the level one well F
is one when negative Y is one that means
when y is negative one so I go to minus
one and that will be where my level one
it's and so on F is 2 when y is negative
two F is negative 1 when y is 1 and so
on ok is that convincing do you see how
we got that ok let me do it again I
don't see anybody nodding so that's kind
of bad news so if I want to know where
the level curve say 1 I try to set F
equal to 1 let's do this one F equals 1
means that negative Y is 1 means that Y
is minus 1 and y equals minus 1 is this
horizontal line on this chart ok and the
same with the others so you can see on
this map that the value of the function
doesn't depend on X if you move parallel
to the x-axis nothing happens if you
move in the Y direction it decreases at
a constant rate that's why the contours
are evenly spaced see how how spaced
apart they are tells you actually how
steep things are so that corresponds
exactly to that picture except that here
with all X coming to the front and Y to
the right
you have to rotate the mat by 90 degrees
to get to that it's an unfortunate
consequence of a usual way of plotting
things in space okay so these horizontal
lines here correspond actually to
horizontal lines here okay second
example let's do 1 minus x squared minus
y squared okay or maybe I'll rewrite it
as 1 minus X square plus y square it's
really the same thing so X Y let's see
where is this function equal to 0 well
we said f is 0 on the unit circle okay
so the 0 level let's say that this is my
unit that's where it's zero what about F
equals 1 well that's when x squared plus
y squared equals 0 well that's only
going to be here so you know let's just
a single point what about F equals minus
1 that's when x squared plus y squared
equals 2 that's a circle of radius
square root of 2 which is about 1.4 so
it's somewhere here
then - so it's negative 1 - 2 similarly
will be X square plus y square equals 3
square root of 3 is about 1.7 and then -
ie will be of radius 2 and so on so what
I want to show here is that it's minus 3
that's minus 2 what I want to show here
is that they are getting closer and
closer about
okay so first its concentric circles
that tells us that we have a shape that
is solid that the graph is going to be a
surface of revolution things don't
change if I rotate and second the
contour the level lines the level curves
are getting closer and closer to each
other that means it's getting steeper
and steeper because I have to travel a
shorter distance if I want my altitude
to change by 1 okay so this top here is
kind of flat and when it gets steeper
and steeper and that's what we are
served on that picture we're okay so
just to show you a few more where did I
put my so for X square plus y squared
the contour plot looks like this maybe
actually I'll make it okay so it looks
exactly the same as this one but the
difference is if you can see the numbers
which are not there so you can see them
then you would know that instead of
decreasing as we move out this one is
increasing as we go out okay so that's
where we use actually the labels on the
level curves that tell us whether things
are going up or down but the contour
plots looks exactly the same for the
next one I had equals y squared - x
squared so the contour plot well let me
actually zoom out so the contour plot
looks like that
so the level curve Cosman to zero is
actually two diagonal lines and if you
look on the plot
say that you started the saddle point in
the middle and you try to stay at the
same level so it looks like a mountain
pass right well there's actually four
directions from that point that you can
go staying at the same height and they
actually on the map they look exactly
like these two as crossing lines okay so
these are things that go on the sides of
the two mountains that are to the left
and right and stay at the same height as
the mountain pass on the other hand if
you go along the Y direction to the left
or to the right then you go towards
positive values and if you go along the
x axis then you get towards negative
values okay
the equation for the function was y
square minus x squared so you can try to
plot them by hand and confirm that it
does look like that but I trust them I
trust my computer and finally this one
well so the contour plot looks a bit
complicated but you can see two things
in the middle you can see these two
regions with these concentric circles to
develop le circles but you know these
closed curves that are concentric and
they correspond to the two mountains and
then at some point in the middle we have
a mountain pass and where we see the two
crossing lines again like on the plot of
X square minus y square minus x squared
and so at this saddle point here if we
go north or south then we'll go down on
either side to the valley and if we go
east or west then we'll go to all the
mountains will go up okay
does that make sense a little bit okay
so you know wedding plots is not easy
but hopefully we'll get used to it very
soon
okay so actually let's say well okay so
I want to point out one thing the
contour plot tells us actually what
happens when we move when we change the
x and y so if I change the value of x
and y that means I'm moving east-west or
north-south on the map and then I can
ask myself does the value of a function
increase or decrease in each of these
situations well that's the kind of thing
that the contour plot can tell me very
quickly
so okay so say for example that I have a
piece of contour plot that looks not
like that maybe this is epic walls one
and this is F equals two and here this
is F equals zero and let's say that I
start at the point say at this point so
here I have x0 y0 and the question I
might ask myself is if I change X or Y
how does F change
well the contour plot tells me that if x
increases and I keep Y constant then
what happens to event X Y well it will
increase because if I move to the right
then I go from 1 to a value bigger than
1 I don't know exactly how much but I
know that somewhere it's somewhere
between 1 and 2 it's more than 1 if X
decreases then F decreases and similarly
I can tell that if Y increases then F
well looks like if I increase Y then F
will also increase and if Y decreases
then F decreases and you know that's the
kind of qualitative analysis that we can
do easily on the contour plot but maybe
we'd like to actually be more precise
than that and tell how fast F jinja's if
I change X on Y ok so to find rate of
change that's exactly where we use
derivatives so
we are going to have to deal with
partial derivatives so I will explain to
you soon why partial so let me just
remind you first if you have a function
of one variable then so let's say f of X
then you have a derivative F prime of X
is also called DF DX and it's defined as
a limit when Delta X goes to 0 of the
change in F so it's not going to fit to
go to the next line it's going to be the
limit as Delta X goes to 0 of the rate
of change so the change in F between X
and X plus Delta X divided by Delta X
sometimes you write Delta F for the
change in F divided by Delta X then you
take the limit of this rate of increase
as Delta X goes to 0 now of course if
you have a formula for F then you know
at least you should know I suspect most
of you know how to actually take the
derivative of a function
you know from its formula so
now how do we do that also and I should
tell you also what this means on the
graph so if I plot the graph of a
function and I have my point X and here
I have half of X how do I see the
derivative well I look at the tangent
line to the graph and the slope of a
tangent line is at prime of X okay and
hope in advertising not every function
has a derivative you have functions that
are not regular enough to actually have
a derivative so in this class we are not
going to actually worry too much about
differentiability but it's good at least
to be aware that you can't always take a
derivative so yes and what else do I
want to remind you of well we also have
an approximation formula which says that
you know if we have the value of f at
some point x0 and when we want to find
the value at a nearby point X close to X
0 then our best guess is that it's f of
x0 plus the derivative F Prime at x0
times Delta X so if you want X minus x0
ok is this kind of familiar to you yeah
I mean maybe with different notations
maybe you call that Delta X or something
maybe you call that x0 plus h or
something but it's it's the usual
approximation formula using the
derivative if you put more terms when
you get the dreaded rated Taylor
approximation but I know that you guys
don't like so
okay so the question is how do we do the
same for a function of two variables f
of X Y so the difficulty there is we can
change X or we can change Y or we can
change both and presumably the manner in
which a changes will be different
depending on whether we change X or Y so
that's why we have several different
notions of derivative
so okay so we have a notation okay so
this is a currently D and it is not a
straight D and it is not a delta it's a
D that kind of curls backwards like that
and the way you read this symbol is
partial okay so it's the special
notation for partial derivatives and
essentially what it means is we are
going to do a derivative where we care
about only one variable at a time that's
why it's partial it's missing the other
variables okay so a function of several
variables doesn't have a usual
derivative it has only partial
derivatives for each variable so the
partial derivative the partial F partial
X at X 0 y 0 is defined to be the limit
when I take a small change in X Delta X
of the change in F divided by Delta X ok
so here I'm actually not changing Y at
all I'm just changing X and looking at
the rate of change with respect to X and
I have the same with respect to Y
partial F partial Y is the limit so I
should say at the point X 0 y 0 is the
limit as Delta Y tends to 0 F so this
time I keep X the same with a change Y
okay so that's the definition of a
partial derivative and we say that a
function is differentiable if these
things exist okay so most of the
functions will see our differentiable
and we'll literally learn how to compute
the partial derivatives without having
to do this of course we'll just use the
usual methods for computing derivatives
so in fact I claim you already know how
to take partial derivatives so let's see
what it means geometrically so
geometrically my function can be
represented by its graph and you know I
fix some point x0 y0 and then I'm going
to ask myself what happens if I change
the value of well if I change the value
of X keeping Y constant so if I keep Y
constant and change X it means I'm
moving forward or backward parallel to
the x axis so that determines for me a
vertical plane ok parallel to the XZ
plane when I fix y equals constant and
now if I slice the graph by that I will
get some curve that goes it's a slice of
the graph of F and now what I want to
find is how f depends on X if I keep Y
constant that means it's the rate of
change if I move along this curve so in
fact if I look at the slope of this
thing so if I draw a tangent line to
this slice then the slope will be
partial F over partial X
I think I have a better picture of that
somewhere yes here it is
okay that's the same picture just with
different colors so I take the clap I
slice it by the vertical plane I get a
curve and now I take the slope of that
curve and that gives me the partial
derivative and finish I just tell you
how so and I should say partial F that
for Y is the same thing but slicing now
by your plane that goes into Y Z
directions okay so I fix I fix X equals
constant that means I slice by a plane
that's parallel to the blackboard I get
a curve and I look at the slope of that
curve okay so it's just a matter of
fungating one variable setting it
constant and looking at the other one
only so how to compute these things
well we actually to find oh there's a
piece of notation I haven't told you yet
so another notation you will see I think
this is what one uses a lot in physics
and this is what one uses a lot in
applied math which is the same thing as
physics but with different notations
okay so there's two different notations
partial F partial X or F subscript X and
they're the same thing well we just
treat Y as a constant and X as variable
and vice versa if we want to find
partial with respect to Y so let me just
finish with one quick example let's say
that I give you f of X y equals x cubed
y plus y squared then partial F partial
X well let's take the derivative so here
it's x cubed times our constant
derivative of x cubed is three times x
squared times the constant
plus what's the derivative of Y squared
zero because it's a constant if you do
instead partial X partial Y then this is
actually a constant times y the
derivative of Y is 1 so that's just X
cubed and the derivative of Y squared is
2y ok so it's fairly easy you just have
to keep remembering which one is a
variable which one is not okay so more
about this next time and we'll also
learn about maxima and minima in several
variables